at this altitude I can
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by ship
station I've been super impressed with
these guys ship station is the shipping
software with the most five-star reviews
now speaking as a former ecommerce CEO
back in a previous incarnation when I
was shipping tens of thousands and then
hundreds of thousands of products this
is what I wish I had way back in the day
as folks adapt to this changing world
these strange times we were all going to
be buying more stuff online than ever
before and if you're an e-commerce
seller or if you want to be selling more
online you have to ask yourself are you
ready to meet the demands of our new
delivery economy you can be ready with
ship station and lots of my friends use
them so why ship station when you're
selling online getting a lot of orders
out fast can be super hard I've
experienced this firsthand how do you
keep track of who gets what which
shipping carrier should you use how do
you process refunds how do you process
returns how do you do all of that are
you getting the best rates shipstation
helps online sellers of any size get
orders out quickly save money on
shipping costs and keep customers happy
they do a few things really really well
you can import more orders from more
places so no matter where you're selling
Amazon Etsy Shopify eBay your own
website wherever ship station brings it
all into one simple interface making it
really easy to manage from any device
including your cell phone your
smartphone you can instantly rate shop
your favorite carriers and this is a
huge deal as a ship station user you can
get access to discounted rates that are
typically reserved for much larger
companies like fortune 500 companies
that meet certain minimums just as an
example ship station just negotiated a
new deal with UPS in which rates are
discounted as
just 62% that has a huge impact on
businesses and on your bottom line your
profit margin and an Amazon Prime world
where people are used to free shipping
small businesses or smaller businesses
can struggle to stay competitive with
high shipping costs shipstation can help
with that you go way beyond ordinary
tracking so there's a self-serve portal
for people who want to know where their
order is when they're gonna get it etc
returns ditto
self-serve it just makes everything
easier that's why shipstation is the
number one choice of online sellers
today you ship more product and less
time with the best rates available and
right now my dear listeners you can try
shipstation free for 60 days when you
use offer code tim TI m there's
absolutely no risk you can start your
free trial without even entering your
credit card info just visit shipstation
dot-com click on the microphone at the
top of the homepage and type in Tim
that's shipstation comm then enter offer
code Tim shipstation dot-com make ship
happen one more time ship station comm
click on the microphone at the top and
type in Tim that's me t IM check it out
this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleep sleep is super important
to me in the last few years I've come to
conclude it is the end-all-be-all that
all good things good mood good
performance good everything seem to stem
from good sleep so I've tried a lot to
optimize it I've tried pills and potions
all sorts of different mattresses you
name it and for the last few years I've
been sleeping on a helix midnight luxe
mattress I also have one in the guest
bedroom and feedback from friends has
always been fantastic it's something
that they comment on helix sleep has a
quiz takes about two minutes to complete
that matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you with helix there's a specific
mattress for each and every body that is
your body also your taste so let's say
you sleep on your side and like a super
soft bed no problem or if you're a back
sleeper who likes a mattress that's as
firm as a rock they've got a mattress
for you too helix was selected as the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by
magazine wired Apartment Therapy and
many others just go to helix sleep calm
slash Tim take their two minutes sleep
quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
ten year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up from you if you don't
love it and now my dear listeners Hilux
is offering up to $200 off of all
mattress orders and two free pillows at
helix sleep comm slash Tim these are not
cheap pillows either so getting two for
free is an upgraded deal so that's up to
$200 off and two free pillows at helix
sleep comm slash Tim that's helix heli79
girls ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show or is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers from
all different fields to tease out how
they do what they do the thought process
is the favorite books the habits etc
that make them so good at whatever they
choose to focus on and my guest today is
Nick cojones ko ko na s on instagram @ n
cojones on twitter at nick cojones nick
is the co-owner and co-founder of the
Alinea group of restaurants which
includes Alinea next the aviary
royster st. Clair supper club and the
aviary NYC Alenia has been named the
best restaurant in america and best
restaurant in the world by organizations
and lists as diverse as the James Beard
Foundation world's 50 best TripAdvisor
Yelp Gourmet magazine and elite traveler
the list goes on his restaurants have
won nearly every accolade afforded to
them recently
Alania had to shut its doors due to
COBIT 19 right alongside restaurants
everywhere all over the world so you can
imagine my surprise when just a few days
ago Nick told me that Alinea had a
record-setting day in fact its highest
revenue day ever
within the last two weeks that's part of
the catalyst for recording this episode
and we dig into the strategies and
tactics that made it possible
and even if you have no interest in
restaurants there's a lot that you can
gain from this episode as it relates to
frameworks thought structures
contingency planning all of that and if
you are in the hospitality industry the
restaurant biz I recognize that Alinea
is a somewhat unusual case but still
there are things to be learned from how
Nick and his team have responded to this
and adapted and innovated in other
places so I suggest listening Nick as a
bit of background has been a subversive
entrepreneur and angel investor since
1996 he spent a decade as a derivatives
trader has co-written three books and
believes in radical transparency in
markets and business is an outsider to
the restaurant industry Nick's approach
to the business of restaurants is
markedly innovative and he's been
featured in Businessweek Fast Company
the New York Times Forbes and Crain's
Chicago Business among many other
publications he's given talks on
innovation entrepreneurship and
experienced design across the country he
is also the founder and CEO of Talk Inc
that's T Ock a reservations and CRM
system for restaurants with more than 10
million dinars and clients in more than
30 countries talk has also recently
launched a to go platform which has
helped restaurants pivot to fulfill
pickup and delivery orders you can find
more on that at explore talk.com
and without further ado please enjoy a
very wide-ranging and tactical
conversation with Nick cook Otis
Nik welcome back to the shelf thanks Tim
great to be back and this is an episode
that I've been looking forward to we've
been chatting over the last handful of
weeks and you've had a few dozen people
request that you go back on my podcast
I've had a few people request the same
and a lot has happened in the last year
and a half but certainly in the last
month and a half and before we get into
the current state of affairs and how in
some ways many ways you've zigged
instead of zagged and approach things
differently let's zoom out to a concept
that we discussed in your first
appearance quite a bit maybe you could
just define it for us and that is
asymmetric bets or asymmetric
opportunities could you define what that
is and then perhaps just describe what
kind of follow-up questions you've been
getting and how you would speak to those
yeah well I mean we covered a lot of
ground I think that first podcast was
three horses or something like that and
you know the over arching theme was
about decision making not outcomes right
so we try to measure I try to measure my
self and my business life and personal
life on on making the decisions not
whether or not they sort of paid off or
not and in business especially your
investing what you're looking for is an
opportunity where if you make the wager
or you make the investment that you know
you you get paid off ATEX but you can
only lose 1x or 2x it's just that simple
you know it's and that doesn't mean like
also that the odds are actually 8 X it's
like a 50/50 odds chance that pays off
more than 50/50 right or
there are unknowable odds and this is
probably more often the case but if
something does happen it's really
consequential as opposed to if it
doesn't happen it doesn't really matter
so we thought getting you know technical
or mathematical about it if you take an
action and X happened and it doesn't
really affect you at all but if Y
happens it's either really really great
or really really bad
that's the asymmetry that we're looking
for and you want to you want to take the
action which either hedges you in case
that that outcome is really terrible or
you invest in it if the outcome is
really great and then knowing that you
did that is is the right path like you
don't the outcome is what it is you
can't really control it most of the time
and so consequently you just go yep I
made the right decision I'm gonna live
with that
and I was just gonna say and I wanted to
pull you off your train of thought but
could you give perhaps an example not
necessarily the current example which we
will get into but are there any examples
that you could use just to illustrate
this for folks for listening yeah of
course you know occasionally in I'll use
an investing example occasionally you
see a situation where a company is very
very solid as a great balance sheet is
doing business you know steadily and and
you know they're not going to go out of
business any time soon but they have an
opportunity that if it if it happens if
it works it you know they it's gonna go
skyrocketing the example I can think of
is actually similar to our current
crisis and that is in 2008 I remember
watching the CEO of Ford on TV and all
the other guys were talking about the
bailout and the tarp
and all that and they were they looked
really nervous and he got up there I was
like yeah we're not gonna take the tarp
money we don't need it and Ford was
trading it like Iowa say it was like a
dollar eighty or share or something at
the time it had been dragged down and
you could just see that they felt that
their business was solid their business
overseas was fine their business in
China was growing and they had planted
the seeds for that and it felt to me
like Ford wasn't gonna go down to a
dollar but I could easily go to five
that's it it's not like you know it's
not like overly complicated and knowing
what I did about the the overall sector
at the time because I was studying yet
that was kind of all I needed to go to
say hey this is a really a symmetric
situation I think what's interesting
after our last talk where we got into it
and more depth a lot of people on
Twitter some started thread saying hey a
lot of these people that are on on
podcasts and people who think about
these sorts of things that I like Nepal
or whoever it may be talking about
asymmetric risk or Talib and and let's
make a list of everything it's
asymmetric and people were like reading
a book is asymmetric or spending time
with your families asymmetric and that's
not the point
it was like yeah those are great
investments of your time and they're
linear you know what we're looking for
is something that is multiplicative that
is logarithmic and I certainly think
reading books is awesome and and
spending time with your family is
awesome
but it's not asymmetric mm-hmm and let's
let's jump into asymmetric risk because
there's asymmetric risk or opportunity
to the upside right where maybe you can
invest very cheaply I'm just making this
up in a drug development Sherpa knee and
it's gonna be worth nothing but your
your downside is capped and very minimal
but if it does in fact clear the
regulatory hurdles and ABC it's going to
be a 20 or 100x
right something like that there are
those examples then there are downside
risks and you are a participant and you
wear many hats but certainly one of
those hats
is in the food and beverage or
restaurant world and many people would
argue that no sector has been so swiftly
decapitated as the the arena of
restaurants and I just be curious to
know if we travel back in time when did
you start to assess this risk so it is
April now and I think we're six or seven
weeks into a quarantine mostly national
I'm a I'm the CEO and founder of talk
which is a reservation system and we
operate in 28 countries and one of those
countries where we have about 20-30
restaurants small presence is hong kong
and when the virus hit China and then
Hong Kong started shutting its borders
we could rapidly see the reservations
going from you know 95% capacity of most
of the restaurants there to zero like
actual zero like they were open ish but
no one was going that certainly woke me
up to the possibility that zero was was
plausible now it's a funny story is that
about three years ago we were assessing
our clearing risk so talk not only does
ordinary reservations but we sell
tickets to events for restaurants or
special tables like chefs tables or
prefix menus and we sell about thirty to
forty million dollars a month of those
four restaurants around the world and
one of the things that we have to assess
is the risk of of how we pay those
restaurants out you can imagine that if
you have a concert or something like
that and you sell the tickets to the
concert and like you know it's the Fire
Island scenario right so you sell all
the tickets to the concert and then
everyone pays their money and
got it and to be clear that's the fyr II
not the yes FY re that not the other one
and and so you you pay out the money to
the concert promoter ahead of time and
then if the concert doesn't take place
or that guy just goes to Jamaica with
the money we're left holding the bag in
the case of the restaurants so we were
trying to assess that that risk and it's
a bit like running a clearing firm and
what our CEO firm just for clarity firm
is is the middle position in a
commodities market so they're a buyer to
every seller and a seller to every buyer
so if I make a transaction with you for
a futures contract
we don't actually make it directly even
though you're the buyer and I'm the
seller I actually sell it to the
clearing firm and you buy it from the
clearing firm I got it so it's kind of
like a title company in a home
transaction right so I remember our CFO
Steve Bernanke really bright guy very
conservative saying to me you know we
shouldn't pay out XYZ restaurants this
far in advance because there's a risk
that they can default and all that and I
said and I have this in an email I said
it's not like every restaurant in
America can close all at once and that
was three years ago I was wrong about
that you know I I never imagined a
scenario that that this could happen and
then in February I I could imagine it I
could imagine it given what's happened I
still thought the probability of it
happening was very low it wasn't like I
was you know prescient in the sense of
like yes for sure this is going to be a
pandemic that sweeps America and even if
it had been you I probably went have
thought that it would result in the kind
of lock downs that it has so but I did
think if it happens we are completely
screwed all right so there's an
asymmetric risk to the downside where
you go like look there's a there's a 90
chance this doesn't happen at this point
or maybe even a 95% chance but if it
does happen we have a load of problems
we have a load of problems for our
restaurants for our employees for talk
in their existential in nature they are
the kind of problems where you go I have
blowout risk I can wake up tomorrow and
have no businesses and talk could be on
the hook for you know five to ten
million dollars which would blow talked
out so I became very aggressively
paranoid with people in my circle and
saying hey look what's going on in Hong
Kong could happen here this is into
February and just just just so I
understand in your circle you mean
within the company employees managers
colleagues within the company yes
correct yeah yeah and you know I called
in our general counsel and said Emily
Grodin a really bright young woman and I
just said I need to understand
everything about unemployment I need to
understand everything about furloughing
people I need to understand all the
benefits I talked to our HR people like
how much can we pay people and they
could still get benefits and I remember
them looking at me going like I why are
you asking these questions like you know
are you are you about to like sell the
company like they weren't thinking
negatively they were thinking like
something must be up but it's probably a
good thing right
and then I called in Steve and I was
like we need to come up with with
methods of tracking the inflow and
outflow of of payments to our companies
by the hour not by the day like things
like that and in terms of the
restaurants you know I had pulled in
Grant Achatz and and our you know our
management team and and just said I
think there's a reasonable chance we
don't have any restaurants in a couple
weeks and for those who don't know since
it's not in your bio you give two or
three lines on on grant yeah sure
absolutely
Grant Achatz is is my business partner
he's also one of the best chefs in the
world renowned for Modernist Cuisine we
like to call it some people call it
molecular gastronomy
we built a Linea together in 2005 and
he's one you know best chef for us and
he's been on all the TV shows and if you
want to learn more about him the best
way to do that is a chef's table the
Netflix series season 2 episode 1 really
really talented dedicated amazing person
who also survives stage 4 cancer ten
years ago grant is is incredible so I
second that recommendation last name
spelling ACH ATZ also both you and grant
appear quite heavily in the 4-hour chef
for those people who might already have
that okay so you called in grant and
yeah and I just said I think there's a
reasonable chance that we don't have any
restaurants in a couple weeks he could
tell I was very serious
Alex Hayes our business development
manager could tell I was very serious so
they weren't looking at me saying like
you know you're crazy
but they also were looking at me like
you know I think you've kind of lost it
a little bit or maybe you're
overstressed these days and I just kept
saying to them like look I hope I'm
wrong but if I'm right we need to do a
lot of things very very quickly and very
well and if we don't we're gonna be in a
world of hurt I think that because I was
a trader on the floor which doesn't
exist anymore you know the thing about a
trading floor is that the markets work
the same as they do now lot slower and
you could watch people though and their
positions so the difference you know in
the 90s and early 2000s is that
when someone was losing a tremendous
amount of money and was stressed out you
could watch them and people had
different reactions like one reaction
was to blame everyone else around them
it wasn't their fault you know the world
conspires against them and they would
lash out and get violent or something
like that some people would what we
called turtle like they put their shell
up and tuck their head in and and just
kind of like sit there and watch the
world fall down around them and it
wasn't a pleasant thing by any stretch
but it was the kind of thing that you
saw fairly often and so what we always
tried to train our people to do was hey
you know the market is much bigger than
you the world is much bigger than you
and it is what it is like you have to
see it as as you see it assess it and
then doing nothing is a choice
doing nothing is is holding tight to
your current position it's like buying
your position again and so if you're
better off selling your position and
getting out you have to do that very
quickly and one of the things that any
any trading book will tell you is that
you're supposed to let your your winners
ride and your losers you're supposed to
lock in but most people do the opposite
of course in every aspect of their life
because when you lock in a loser
you have you have ended that that
outcome in a negative fashion you've
reinforced it like you you've lost the
game the game is over
whereas if you buy lock in what do you
mean well I mean in the case of trading
like if you buy a stock at a hundred
dollars a share and it goes to 80 if you
hold it you go like well there's a
chance it could go to 110 right if you
sell it at 80 you've locked in a $20
loss it's right on like the game is over
of that particular trade and so I think
a lot of people tend to do the opposite
of what you should do which is when you
buy the stock at 100 it goes to 110 they
sell it and they lock it in because why
hey I made a good decision and I won and
that one's over
it's the converse and it's exact
opposite in two
leave with what you should be it's
intuitively exactly the right thing that
your brain is telling you to do it's
saying you know lock in the the feel
good get the get the serotonin release
or whatever and and ignore the bad
like like let's just let it ride because
like it'll probably turn around you know
or it's cheaper like I loved it at 100
at 80 right and you can ride that all
the way down to zero and it's no
different with our restaurants when when
we were looking at the possibility let's
just say that that we didn't do the lock
downs in America but demand went down 40
percent demand goes down 40 percent in a
restaurant you're probably losing money
every week and you're gonna have to make
really hard decisions about staffing
about hours about food purchasing all
those things and so that day and it was
I can tell you it was March 4th we I
basically said we need to get like
contingency plans together like nothing
happened no problem
business as usual if it's regional and
people can't travel and our demand is
down 20 or 30 percent what's our plan
for that
what's our staffing plan what's our
what's our purchasing plan what's what's
our our PR plan for lack of a better
term like what is our messaging to the
world what should our menu items be what
feels appropriate how do we message that
to our teammates and our staff who may
not understand the situation and then of
course you know what happens if we're
mandated to shut what do we do and by
making all those decisions at a time
where it wasn't yet a panic when events
started to unfold you you're kind of
like you know dust off plan D and then
you just execute because the
decision-making is much easier to make
when you're not
when you're not in the throes of battle
so to speak so if we if we then look at
the play-by-play so you call all your
teammates your staff together what what
message do you deliver to the you've
spoken with management you've spoken
with grant or presumably you spoken with
management but what what what is the
message that you sort of deliver when
things start to go either before they go
sideways or when they start to go
sideways yeah so just before you know if
things were really going sideways and
you could see that in Seattle
specifically you could see that there is
both an outbreak and the restaurant
business was starting to go down the
tubes and on March 8th I tweeted that
the hospitality industry in the United
States is about to be decimated it's 4%
of GDP and then hotels and airlines are
are coming right after and that's you
know
March March 8th that same day I brought
in I think we have about 25 managers
between front of house and back of house
at our five restaurants and we brought
them all into a meeting and I just said
this is coming and we need to institute
new rules as to how everybody works and
so we instituted mandatory temperature
checks hourly hand-washing both of which
are logged normally if there's like a 1
p.m. or noon call time for a front of
house to do side work people kind of can
come anytime between you know 12:00 and
12:30 or whatever I was saying if
someone's not there within five minutes
of call time exactly 12 o'clock to get
their temperature check they can't come
in the building if they've traveled from
Europe or Asia
and last 2 weeks they have to quarantine
for 10 days and all that sounds fairly
normal now at the time what I was
relying on two things one I was looking
at what they were doing in China to to
combat this businesses
it wasn't hard to find information on
that and then I also talked to a doctor
here in Chicago about you know is it
safe for employees to go in with this
like what precautionary measures can we
take for their safety and the safety of
our of our customers and mind you this
is when we were still open like we were
not closed at that point and I do know
that there was a bit of cynicism on this
because they were kind of going like Oh
Nick's the owner guy and he's not here
during service and there's no way we can
stop our service in the middle of you
know a busy night serving 300 people to
have all 55 people on the staff wash
their hands every hour it's just not
going to happen and I can see that look
on a few of their eyes like man he's out
of touch and doesn't get it and as soon
as I saw that I shut it down hard I
basically just said like there will be
no jobs in four weeks and we need to get
way ahead of this curve and anybody who
doesn't take this seriously is just out
the door no HR calls no anything we are
in we are in a wartime footing and the
smiles kind of went off their face as I
went down the line and I just said we
are gonna work as hard as we possibly
can for all of our mutual benefit and
for our community's benefit and we're
gonna feed people and we're gonna feed
each other and we're gonna get each
other jobs and we're gonna pay you and
I'm not gonna take any money and grants
not gonna take a salary and all the
management team the ownership team is
not going to take a salary that's how
seriously we take it and by the end of
that meeting all those procedures were
in place the next day there were one or
two people who did not want to do it and
they were asked to leave and this is pre
tsunami right I mean you're sort of
seeing based on the canary in the coal
mine of Seattle and Washington that the
tide kind of flowing out so to speak
right like okay yeah
yes not this is not normal yeah we were
still doing business you know we were
still open and I thought that there was
a chance that you know again I thought
it was like well we're at like 60% now
or 70% this is going to come to Chicago
but even if it doesn't come to Chicago
even if it just stays on the west coast
it still affects us tremendously
right so you know day by day I think it
became very evident that we were going
to be mandated to close and that's when
I went from restaurant mode like of like
okay well the restaurants we kind of
know what we're gonna do we've got these
plans to the talk mode of holy cow if
every restaurant in America shut talk
has no business like we're a four year
old five year old startup with a hundred
employees may I pause you for one second
yeah of course see you have the startup
with a hundred employees but you also
have all these restaurants so you said
you had the plans in place what were the
plants for those restaurants I mean if
well yeah the plan for the restaurant
was if if the governor's office mandated
that they closed we would well first of
all let me back up we we run the
restaurants very differently than a lot
of folks we eliminated tipping ten years
ago in order to accomplish a lot of the
things I think the industry needs we try
to treat all of our employees as the
professionals that they are so what I
mean by that is that a lot of people
think of a waiter or waitress as
embodying this this role in society of
servitude and certainly we're in service
of our customers but in trying to give
them great hospitality but for many of
our employees you know most I would say
this is their chosen profession they are
highly skilled at what they do
we create a unique environment and
experience for our guests and that's why
we're we're so successful and the more
successful we are as a team
the more successful these folks are as
professionals we have servers that make
you know well into 150 plus thousand
dollars a year but we don't do it with
tips and so we also provide a 401k with
four percent matching benefits we also
have healthcare benefits that people
vest into after just you know a month or
two of work we have Family Medical Leave
Act you know paid paid parental leave
all these things that I think and we'll
probably get to it in a little bit but
all these things I think that that
people are aware of now because the
industry you know was forced to close
and and you know you're talking about 11
million workers in the United States
that are in the hospitality business and
that aren't gonna be displaced by robots
anytime soon you know we ran that very
very differently and so the
considerations that I had was okay if
we're not doing any business and we have
no revenue coming in what is the best
way over the short term month or two to
ensure that these folks have healthcare
ensure that they're taken care of what
is a furlough look like what is
unemployment insurance look like what
kind of capital reserves do we have that
we can pay stipends to them what other
work could we give them that could
produce revenue that isn't our core
business you know and so all of those
things were considered and when the
shelter-in-place order came I was
watching on my computer and I heard the
governor Governor Pritzker say that he's
ordering all the restaurants closed and
I closed that window and I immediately
called our HR and our general counsel
and I said I'm gonna graph the letter
furloughing all 300 people but what
we're gonna do is we're gonna pay the
benefits out at the level at which we
can keep them on that they can get
unemployment insurance but can also
retain their health care we are going to
pay a three hundred thousand dollar
stipend
to all the employees so $1,000 for every
employee on their paycheck as a bonus to
tide them over so last paycheck comes
this Friday they everybody gets an extra
thousand dollars and then what we're
gonna do is we need to understand the
rules on how to hire everybody back and
what the timing of that looks like and
certainly at that point we didn't know
what that how successful we would be and
in the plans I'll tell you about in a
second and I wrote that letter to the
employees and I have to tell you like it
was it was super emotional I was at home
and it was really tough because in some
ways I felt like I knew the plan and I
knew what we might be able to accomplish
but I also thought that there was a
really high chance that we'd fail at it
and also there was you know it's a sense
of helplessness like there's not much
you can do so I knew I think what I said
to my wife was I knew I was making the
right decision both ethically and
strategically and yet it still felt
terrible so so that was really hard and
then I sent that off and I probably
wallowed for like an hour and then I
went okay we need to start feeding
people we're in the business of selling
food and selling emotional connections
with that food and cultural connections
and we're gonna start doing that and so
you know we had already decided that we
were gonna try to carry out which is the
farthest thing from what we do normally
and yeah just to paint a picture yeah so
Alinea is like MoMA meets immersive
theater meets hear a pin drop quiet
kitchen with art pieces being brought
out to you it is as far from takeout as
you could possibly imagine
or carry huh yeah it's as far from
carryout as you can imagine and you know
I I said to grant I'm like we got to do
$30 comfort food and we need to do it at
volume now as a as a contrast what would
you say the average sort of ticket purse
per person or per table prices normally
it's it's you know with with wine food
service about $350 a person so okay
should we do I'm on your you're going to
one tenth of that I mean like let's we
can talk a little bit of numbers like we
do 128 people a night at Alinea and we
have a staff for 64 seats we have a
staff of about 85 people that make that
happen
they get there at 4:00 in the morning
5:00 in the morning for the morning prep
team and they're there till 2:00 in the
morning so the cost is you might imagine
of running all of that labor for 20
hours a day and then the night cleaning
person
there's the door doesn't lock 365 days a
year is a 24/7 operation to keep that
going and we do about 20 million dollars
in revenue a year it's it's a very
successful business and we built that up
from our first year doing about four and
a half million in sales it's really
really hard work to make it's like
running a theater like you said it's
it's like every night is Showtime if the
fishmonger doesn't show up with the fish
that morning the people are still
showing up at 6:00 p.m. and there's just
no excuse not to have excellence because
everybody's coming they're expecting a
transformative experience and if we fall
even a little bit off of a really high
mark they consider that horrific because
it's their special occasion you know
it's the one time they're gonna go to
Alinea and see that it's like going to
see the stones and if the stones suck
you're like oh god I waited 30 years to
see the Rolling Stones and they were no
good no they bring it every night it's
hard work you know I mean they're like
80 years old and they're still doing a
great job so we have that attitude of
make it happen just do it like figure it
out
yeah just just as a side note because I
think it'll I think it's kind of
entertaining so good food like good
tasting food again we're gonna we're
gonna segue back to comfort food and
just what a transition that is and you
and I have not spoken about this in
depth because I wanted to save it for
this conversation in terms of making
that hop and the specifics but they're
good tasting food is table stakes right
at Alinea could you what is the I think
it's embroidered is it not it's on a
wall what is the expression flavor is
for well yeah great should I say that
it's a yeah I think at one point
actually when you're doing 4-hour chef
you got a kick out of this Grant had a
napkin that someone embroidered that
said flavour is for and I think
I mean it's not it's not exactly PC but
I I think it's like yeah that's that's
given like making food taste good at
that level it better damn well taste
good and honestly that for people at
that level that's not the hard part
that'd be like telling Picasso like you
know hey you know can you do a portrait
of my daughter and make it look like her
and the answer of course is of course he
can like you know that's like he was
doing that when he was 12 and it was
unbelievable he was a prodigy what are
you gonna do when you're 60 to do
something new different interesting
better how are we gonna to through food
and through your experience and sitting
down there create an emotional
experience for you with food and
services the medium well that sounds
like that sounds like pretentious
like I get that like I get that
that sounds like potentially like the
worst art house project in the world
which which means it's even harder to
pull off know what I mean so what we
always tell people in any interview
you'll ever hear with me
you'll hear when people say well what's
the point of millenia and I say fun and
delicious and everyone's like yeah but
what about the science or what about the
art house or what about the pin drop in
the kitchen and I'm like nope fun
delicious like if you're not having fun
at Alinea if you don't get the joke if
you think that we are making fun of you
we fail miserably but if you go there
and you're laughing with us and you are
surprised and excited we all win
it's it's meant to be that and by the
way we fail all the time at it but we
try really hard to keep it approachable
so let's let's flash forward done
because now all of these things that
make a Linea Linea many of them are gone
right I mean it's just that the palette
of colors has been reduced to carry out
or yeah I mean something like it's we
didn't know what we were gonna do and I
think everybody on our team that the
close-in team as we were trying to
figure this out kept going back to
things we knew and we were on a chain
text message because there's so much
going on and one of our employees kind
of was modeling in talk like well we can
do 125 meals a night and we can do it
between a 6 o'clock pickup in the 9
o'clock pickup and and we'll have this
many employees and this many dishwashers
and all that and I remember I replied
there are no chefs there are no
dishwashers there are no cooks there are
no owners and there is no restaurant get
it through your heads like none
of what we had last week exists we're
doing something completely different
we have to do it inexpensively because
no one's gonna want to spend $200 on a
pickup meal it's also tone-deaf we're in
the middle of freaking pandemic right
it's gonna have to cost like 30 35 bucks
it's gonna have to be comfort food
because it's still kind of winter here
it needs to be highly delicious it needs
to be transportable and it needs to beat
the out of ordinary like delivery
food pickup food
and then we need to do it a scale that
the revenue makes sense if we're doing a
hundred of them at 35 bucks a night
that's thirty five hundred dollars with
the scale of our employee level and our
lease and the kind of ingredients we buy
thirty five hundred dollars a night is
fine if you if you have a small sandwich
shop it's probably great you probably
have two or three employees we have
nearly a hundred at that restaurant
our annual payroll there is you know six
and a half seven million dollars so your
guys you're not getting the scale of the
problem you know and I remember I call
grant and he was like well we could do
like a beef wellington because that's
always delicious and we can do them
individual size and we buy at the
currently we buy beef from a ranch in
Colorado called 7x ranch which makes a
great product and you know the
Wellington's would have to be 50 or 60
bucks each and I was just like it's got
to be 35 bucks like you have to come up
with something 35 bucks he said well I
could do a short rib beef wellington
because short ribs way less expensive
than tenderloin and you'll still be
really delicious the sauce will be the
same and all of a sudden you know three
days later we turned on Talk which we
built this other thing which I can tell
you about in a minute talk to go and we
put up 500 for sale for the weekend on
Friday every Sunday and they sold out in
like five minutes and we also offered
wine to go with that and we sold like a
couple hundred bottles of wine and
suddenly we're like oh like hey we
brought in like twenty thousand dollars
of revenue at night we can hire back
like 30 people and by the way we need to
because we got to produce five hundred
beef Wellington's the first day was was
tricky because the pickup we'd never
done a pickup before but we kind of went
like well it's the smoothest way to do a
contactless pickup
so we built two-way text messaging into
talk and people just pulled up and we
had an iPad out front and people had
masks on and gloves and they popped
their trunk and we put the food in the
trunk and off they go and lo and behold
by 7:00
the first night we had served all 500
and people were posting him on Twitter
saying wow this is a really joyful thing
in the midst of all this craziness and
what always happens with with us in a
good way and with grant god bless him
like you know guys a freaking fighter on
Sunday he was like you know I think we
could do 750 tomorrow like 500 is easy
and by the following weekend we were
doing 1250 at night and we had
reemployed about half our staff in a
week and then we kind of looked midweek
and we went okay what do we do it next
now we know how to do this like hey we
got five under our belt I think it's
safe to get next and royster our other
two of our other restaurants going and
by the way we have a cocktail bar let's
start doing cocktail prepaid cocktail
packages cocktail kits out of aviary and
then offer them up with these meals so
we started engaging Nick mock up in for
a second yeah please so a question that
I'm sure some listeners are wondering is
how do you produce that number of meals
safely without packing employees
together yeah absolutely that's
certainly part of the trick first thing
you have to understand is that on a
normal night at Alinea with 128 people
you're looking at about 2,200 to 2,500
plates going out of the kitchen we have
a big open kitchen it doesn't look like
a traditional French kitchen it looks
more like like a lab or something like
that and so what we did is we took all
the dining room space and we we spaced
all of that out prep kitchen next door
that we use all the time during the day
and the important thing to remember is
that the intricacy of what we do at
Alinea and normally with those 2,000
plates that goes out is highly complex
you've got 15 16 different dishes each
with 15 or 16 different components very
precise by doing five hundred to a
thousand beef Wellington's that are all
identical to one another along with the
sides and the rubbish
mashed potatoes and all that it's
actually much simpler than what we do
normally and so what we did was we did
the temperature check the mandatory
hand-washing the masks the gloves but we
spread it out throughout the entire
restaurant so that the space where
diners normally are wasn't being used so
we used that as staging for all the
boxing of the food and whatnot right so
we were able to do it in a way that was
safe and it's really important to
remember - and this is something I think
a lot of people early on didn't think
about in in Chicago we have 82 major
grocery stores for five million people
if one of those nodes goes down like if
you think about a computer network if
you have a network of 16 computers and
one of those nodes goes down you notice
right but if you have one with 64,000
nodes and one of them goes down you
don't really notice you know that's
that's the Internet in a nutshell right
that's that's that's computing in a
nutshell early on there were some folks
in the industry that were calling for
restaurants to not be allowed to do
carry out at all and is it 100% safe
well it seems to be the case and there's
broad consensus on this that food is
safe and packaging is probably safe like
99% safe now
the mail is still being delivered and
we're all getting Amazon packages so
what we were left with is really the
safety not of our customers which seem
to be very very safe but the safety of
our employees and so that's what we took
very very seriously and and first I
should also add anybody who didn't want
to come into work didn't have to write
any one who felt unsafe or was in giving
care to elderly parents and it was a bad
risk reward no one had to work there
their their reemployment is in no way
contingent on whether they decide to
work during this time
what we found though is that most people
wanted to work and in addition to being
reemployed we put everyone at $15 an
hour we
not no you know so if you were a
dishwasher you made fifteen bucks an
hour if you were the head chef of Lynnea
the sous-chef a manager who is making
$150,000 a year before you were getting
$15 an hour and we did that to make
everyone equal and then we said if we
make money doing this we're gonna take
the profits of that money and we're
gonna distribute it amongst all the
employees and a recapitalisation fund
for the restaurant and could you never
felt-like sir still like part of it yeah
I'm the on that guy have interrupts I
apologize but the because I know people
are gonna wander recapitalisation can
you just explain that real quickly
we don't have spent too much time on it
what does that mean yeah no I basically
we're gonna need runway to keep everyone
employed after we reopen one of the
things that people don't realize I think
in the industry and in public in general
although it's it's certainly dawning on
everybody is that okay Congress passed
the cares Act and that's certainly a
huge help to small businesses across the
board they did so very very quickly and
consequently the the there's a June 30th
deadline as of the time where we're
recording this and it may be changed but
basically you can you can apply for the
payroll protection program rehire
everybody but you got to spend all that
money if you want it to be forgivable by
June 30th but restaurants won't be
reopened for ordinary business by June
30th and even if they were how many
people are gonna show up and feel safe
right so it's one thing to hire
everybody back but then what happens on
July 1 when you're your demand is down
70% and all of a sudden you have
ordinary expenses an ordinary payroll
again and your lease that you signed in
2016 so what we wanted to do was try to
make enough money now that we could have
you know a capital pool where we could
weather the storm not now but over the
six months after
were allowed to reopen and it remains to
be seen of course whether or not this
works but what I didn't want to do was
was wait to see what happened like every
step along the way I kept saying great
I'm glad Congress is doing this I'm
working with the independent restaurant
coalition but I also want to keep
working like you know I don't want to
rely solely on you know Congress or the
some guidance in the SBA whether or not
they change this June 30th date or not
like I can't really control that even
though they should change it and I want
them to and we've we've pushed them to
because it'd be good for the industry as
a whole and for the economy as a whole I
can't personally as an individual rely
on that and so we we've been working
really really hard to scale up all of
our operations so we actually make money
during this time and then we're gonna
pay out that money to the staff so they
they can you know take care of
themselves and all that but then we also
said like look we want to guarantee your
employment even when it doesn't make
sense come September that's the goal and
they it's got another question or just
dig into one aspect of this that that
may be a dead end or it may be
interesting to people you're just
mentioning a few minutes ago about
repurposing it the dining space in other
words the spaces outside of the kitchen
but still within the restaurant for this
takeout right for the meals that you
were delivering for say thirty-five
dollars a pop was part of your ability
to execute that the use of induction
stove tops that could be moved around
and put all over the place because
that's something I remember noticing
very very obviously when I walked into
the sort of the main and I know you have
multiple spots but within Alinea so this
sort of may and alien autopsy this is
sterile cooking environment where the
induction stove tops these I mean if you
imagine for people who have no idea what
this is like like a very very thin boxed
boardgame I mean something roughly that
size that you can plug in anywhere and
boil a huge pot of water within a matter
of minutes using my understanding is
some type of
sort of I get what magnetic induction I
suppose but did you use those in the
dining space or was that primarily a
prep and kind of packaging area yeah
it's a good thought but we didn't really
need to we were able to to do everything
we need to do between our prep kitchen
and our main kitchen again like keep in
mind like it's a lot of food
if you look on Grant's Instagram you'll
see some pictures where you know there's
you know the packaging for 500 of them
across all the the the pass and you know
they're pleading it up you know for
packaging but in terms of the cooking we
didn't need to do that it was more in
terms of the packaging and staging for
pickup and whatnot that went out into
the dining rooms again it's a ton of
food but it's less than we normally do
did I'm not in the restaurant world but
I imagine that and correct me if I'm
wrong but that on top of low or no I
shouldn't say demand but rather ability
to service customers in the usual way
that there are some supply chain
disruptions did you guys not run into
any supply chain issues you know we're
starting to now but early on that all
the food that you might imagine that
would normally be distributed to
thousands of restaurants almost
everybody was buying nothing so early on
we actually found that that we had some
distributors who would call us up and
say hey I've got 800 pounds of XYZ
that's about to go bad in four days do
you want it so we were yeah so you know
we I remember like probably like day
five or six we you know we didn't want
to be selling wine out of our cellar
because it would again a little
tone-deaf trying to sell you know like
hey it's a pandemic buy a $250 bottle of
wine right so we were going out into the
market and buying wine from distributors
and when we would reach you know the
distributor
and they would email us back they would
be like what do you mean you want to buy
wine and we're like yeah we need to buy
like you know 50 cases for the next
couple days and they would go like what
are you what are you doing yeah and and
so so again like I mean you know sounds
bad but from a trading perspective when
you're the only buyer it's like the in
scene and trading places with Eddie
Murphy going like you know he's got all
the frozen concentrated orange juice
right if you don't know the movie
reference it's worth watching old movies
there's time now but you know it's like
we would just go like well you know
they're asking $22 a bottle offer them
12 and we'll buy it all and and still
doing that you know it's like we put in
a wine order this morning most
restaurants are not are not buying wine
right now they're there's their wine
cellars again about the asymmetry of
things like you want to be a buyer when
everyone in the world says that there's
it's totally not worth buying as long as
the thing you're buying has some
intrinsic value and vice versa you know
yes let me let me hop in because I want
to try to put myself in the in the shoes
of some listeners you're gonna say oh my
god like these guys have huge cast
surpluses they're generating incredible
revenue of course they can weather the
storm now if we just take that as a as a
position right which I think I'll it
seems yes for people take what I'd love
to talk about is or if to hear you talk
about really is number one what types of
restaurants you think will make it and
that could be intrinsically because they
have certain characteristics or because
they adapt in certain ways and then what
are some of the things you wish
restaurants would do more of and less of
right for instance a lot of restaurants
are using gift certificates I don't know
how you feel about that but I'd be
interested in hearing the to the first
point like who's going to survive you
and I were chatting last week or maybe
it was
time time-space has collapsed so it's
hard for me to say maybe was a few days
ago
and I it was a few days ago and a friend
of mine was playing as he called it meet
Santa Claus thank you Matt and
delivering Franklin's barbecue to his
friends in Austin which is an incredible
gift Franklin's barbecue for those of
you don't know is this iconic barbecue
spot where normally you would have to
wait hours and hours and hours there is
a line that will take you three to four
hours if you are lucky enough to get to
the door before it sells out completely
it is incredibly popular right and I
remember you were like yeah franklin's
will be fine
which I would tend to agree with right
it's kind of like if people are looking
at distressed debt and real estate it's
like yeah the Pebble Beach probably
would be fine maybe like the BTRC tear
like who knows right and I'm not helping
it's just a hypothetical but it's a
name-brand
in that respect which I'm sure has some
value in terms of resiliency but who do
you thinks gonna going to make it
through and what are the characteristics
of the things that they might do yeah so
one of the things that it was
interesting in a in a difficult way when
this all happened was that as much as I
was scared and and to be clear I was
very scared as to what would happen just
as much as everyone else's like you know
yeah we have pretty good capital
reserves and whatnot but we chose to do
that you know during the good years the
last couple years we always held money
back we didn't pay it all out to our
investors or ourselves and we did that
because when things were going really
well
you know we expanded over 15 years to
five restaurants I watched other groups
during that time expand to 20 25 30
restaurants and thought to myself
there's no way that that they can be
managing all that well I don't think
unless they're doing something in which
case I need to learn from them you know
but we were always very conservative in
keeping those capital accounts and
whatnot but more than anything else
we're scrappy like people don't realize
people think I wrote a track
bell tolling and then like retreated to
some island somewhere like since the day
we opened Alinea which was 15 years ago
coming up May 4th I've been engaged
every single day with with that
restaurant with Grant with our team as
his grant personally as have steeper
nakki and other key people that we have
it is not glamorous and then we're
scrappy like well we'll just get in
there and do ourselves I'll tell
you what kind of restaurant we'll
survive Eric Rivera used to work for us
and he has a place called Auto AD do in
in Seattle and he is very vocal on
Twitter right now in in in not always a
totally positive way because he sees a
lot of big companies and big hospitality
people saying you know that the industry
is gonna get bailed out and this and
that and Eric's just like it I'm
selling burgers and next week we're
gonna do a steak house and then by the
way if you want to pay it forward we'll
sell a thousand bowls soup every week
for you know people who are in need and
anybody can buy one of those and he is
created in the last three or four weeks
probably 20 different concepts of carry
out delivery he's doing his own delivery
fleet already he's figured that out and
he was a development cook for us and
moved to the west coast what does a
development cook yeah he just basically
like he started off in our kitchens and
then he didn't really didn't really love
or thrive in the environment of not just
grinding out I'll deal in your kitchen
every day and so what he did was he we
when we did research on something or we
would try to figure out new products or
new ideas or new dishes or whatnot or
you just needed someone to go like get
me 42 different kinds of grass-fed beef
and we're gonna figure out which one
we're gonna serve it next for our steak
house he would do all that sort of stuff
so he was a research chef bass
and you look at what he's managed to do
and what he says on Twitter is like look
I've got eight employees I don't have a
ton of money and I know for a fact
there's no chance that I won't be open
in two years because I just wake up
every day and do whatever it takes to
make my payroll and make enough money to
keep my place open now what was his name
again one more time Eric Rivera Eric
Rivera and you know it's like he's
really vocal on Twitter and I think he's
pissing a lot of people off and he's
gotten in that Eric Rivera cooks is his
handle on - yeah that's what I was
trying to find you know he even gets
into it with me at times because you
know early on like in this like I feel
like I need to I have enough of a
platform in the industry where I have to
be a little bit careful on balancing my
criticism with my encouragement you know
and so I think he was kind of like you
know hey Coco knows why are you you know
why aren't you supporting this or that
and yeah I watch what he's doing as
opposed to some other folks who-who
turtled to get back to our earlier
conversation where they just kind of
went like well it's a hopeless situation
there's nothing I can do so there's a
bit of this this misery porn going
around with all not just the hospitality
industry but with with everything every
industry every business saying you know
what was me we'll never make it kind of
thing and this is a terrible situation
but I have a huge belief in human
ingenuity and the ability of people to
be resilient and things people make are
never as structurally sound as the
people themselves like this is not a
unique situation as much as we'd like to
think it is pandemics have been going on
throughout human history it's just that
none of us walking around has lived
through one before and so if you study
history and if you if you read accounts
which I did right at the beginning of
1918 pandemic and what happened in 1920
through 1928
there's the roaring 20s people party
their brains off afterwards and but
right now if you pick up a newspaper and
you read all you read about and all that
anyone wants to hear about is how
hopeless and awful the situation and how
broken society is and we have massive
problems but we could look at that and
say wow this has really put a lens up to
the things we need to fix
let's get fixing and so the kinds of
places that will will do that you know
the Franklin's barbecue story is perfect
like that guy didn't he wasn't like he
didn't grew up like barbecuing he
figured the out made a brand for
himself there's no chance that
Franklin's barbecue doesn't exist in two
years and then also the other thing that
will happen is just like when you have a
forest fire and then the forestry blooms
you know that there's some 25 year old
chef out there and she's been itching to
do her own restaurant but she couldn't
afford the leases and she couldn't find
the backers and all that and a year from
now there's gonna be some empty
restaurant that's with a perfect kitchen
that she's gonna be able to get at
half-price and all of a sudden she's
gonna kick our ass like the new Alinea
is gonna come a year and a half from now
to kick our butt and that's a good thing
like that's the stuff that that we need
to start focusing on I think it's a as
if we're if we're looking at I mean I
think the I agree with you that I think
the the hope is important to Kindle and
highlight whenever possible because it
is so easy and I've certainly struggled
in the last few weeks I'm not trying to
compare myself to anyone who is who's
out of work but everyone is fighting
battles we know nothing about a lot of
people in my life also family members
who are in the service industries have
been laid off and it's it's a
tough time and it is very easy to
succumb to despair particularly if you
are only ingesting news that highlights
hopelessness if that makes any sense if
we look at the if we look at the
tactical so I totally agree with you
they mean the opportunity is just gonna
be incredible for the you know that 25
year old woman or any up-and-comer or
person who's simply been waiting in the
wings looking for opportunities I mean
within the next year or two there gonna
be a lot of opportunities if we're
looking at tactics right now what are
some of the things that you think are
not a good idea what are bad ideas that
people in the restaurant world are
pursuing and yeah what are some of the
good ideas so you mentioned that the
gift certificate thing and I know that
like week one people love their their
neighborhood restaurants and I'm glad
they do and I do as well by the way I'm
a frequent diner and I've got all my
favorites and so people wanted to know
what they could do and there was this
whole movement about gift certificates
and someone in New York set up a site
that they called the restaurant bonds
which showed that they don't really
understand what a bond is they were just
basically a Groupon and it was not only
gift certificate but it was a gift
certificate that was at a 25% discount
all the GoFundMe started Yelp did a
terrible thing with GoFundMe to like
create you know a hundred thousand
automatically generated GoFundMe pages
for restaurants including my own which I
shot down and they killed the program
you know it makes people feel good to
give to support other people and I
certainly don't want to ever discourage
that a gift certificate is a liability
on your balance sheet and if you take
say twenty-five thousand dollars from
people for a GoFundMe or gift
certificate first of all
the scale of your payroll and you know
if the restaurant has 40 50 employees
you can just do the math on the back of
your hand you know like you know they're
making just call it $15 now or 10 hours
a day like multiplied by 50 you're gonna
cover like a day at payroll with it with
a gift certificate drive or a GoFundMe
maybe two days maybe three you know if
you're hugely successful maybe every
employee gets a few hundred dollars and
of course you could say like Nick while
you're being really cynical like that's
a few hundred dollars they didn't have
but what I'm saying is that you're much
better off channeling that to other
organizations that can leverage it more
more impactful II you know world central
kitchen for example the word Jose Andres
is doing if you want to help your local
restaurant buy food from them because if
you buy the gift certificate and then
you go use it in four months they spent
that money four months ago you know one
of the big problems that a lot of
restaurants had is that they were paying
for food that they bought four weeks ago
with next weeks of revenue and the gift
certificate does exacerbates that
problem it just it's like mortgaging
their future what's interesting is that
when I criticize the gift certificates a
lot of restaurants didn't understand how
the finances on that work they didn't
understand how that shows up in their in
their balance sheet and we're very much
thinking that I was trying to hurt them
I was not I was actually trying to
trying to help so it's again it's very
tricky how in in the midst of a crisis
you you try to you try to be positive
and educate the public and and even your
fellow business owners
similarly there's there's a really
high-end push to sue insurance companies
for business interruption insurance and
you know that's a five year process
that's not going to save your restaurant
next week and that's not gonna help your
employees next week so all these things
are
our thoughts that people had really
really fast and again I think that's why
it went to the planning ahead if you're
acting as a reaction to a really bad
situation it's very easy to make bad
decisions quickly if you've considered
the various possibilities that can occur
and what you will do at that time it's
it's like being an athlete that goes
okay well if we get to this part this is
the play we run and you just do it it's
not a hard decision and then you you act
it out that's those are the folks that
are that are gonna make it in every in
every business through this sort of
thing and and also that's of course the
problem with our government too right
we had some of these these play books in
place and we were spending money on them
every year and then people said well
while we're spending money on something
that never happens right maybe we should
just save that money or spend it on
something else or give people tax cuts
with it that's the sort of failure of
leadership that is happening nationally
internationally but also locally and a
small basis with many businesses and I
don't know how you change that globally
I really don't but well I think I think
we can start with those with people
listening and how they implement things
and so I had a clarifying question but I
also want to maybe underscore one thing
which is many people listening will say
well that's great if you had the
foresight to plan and determine
contingency a B C and D before all this
hit but a lot of people didn't do that
and I would just say and I'd love to
hear you add to this after I ask a
clarifying question that it's it's not
too late because there's still so much
uncertainty in the next two weeks for
weeks to months fill in a blank you can
still ask yourself what if this happens
versus that and think about what you
will do in those situations in advance
right that's that's still very much
possibility
for a lot of people but the quick
clarifying question I had might seem
superficial but you mentioned that a lot
of restaurants are paying for the food
they bought four weeks ago with the
revenue from the following front from
next week let's just say right so I
imagine that something like a net 30
terms does that mean that you guys do
not pay your vendors using terms like
that or just that you have such a cash
reserve you have such a margin of safety
in that that buffer that you don't have
to depend on next week's income to pay
for what you bought four weeks ago the
answer is actually both about five or
six years ago we realized that if we
called the vendors of our more expensive
items meat fish wine that sort of thing
and we said hey we'll make you our
exclusive vendor for the next three
months and we'll probably spend about
two hundred twenty thousand dollars
during that time what sort of discount
will you give us if we prepay for that
almost like a futures contract right so
instead of getting net ninety or net
sixty which is what every restaurant
tries to get we actually negotiate a
discount by prepaying that and then you
know sort of truing up afterwards so for
our big-ticket items we try to stay a
couple months ahead on payments in order
to get more favorable terms and better
products and that's something that when
I when I talk to even big restaurant
groups about that there are certainly
some that do that it's very rare you
know you're looking at some big hotels
that do that whatnot but not that many
and then the other part is exactly what
you said which is you know for the for
the vendors that just are smaller they
won't do that or we just sign the
standard terms we have a capital account
that we keep which is you know accounts
receivable accounts payable and our
accounts payable they were always gonna
be able to cover that we're never going
like well if business goes down 30% next
week we're not going to be able to pay
for four weeks ago now of course
everyone can say like well that's
because you're a busy restaurant or
whatever but when we first started that
was you know my dad used to run his own
business he was only high school
educated and he was like every time I
tried to complicate things when I was in
college and I talked to him about his
business he would be like it's three
shoe boxes Nick it's the money in the
money out and then the third box is what
paid for your college it's the money
that's left over as he is like so so you
hear if you worked with me you would
hear me say that a lot like I will get
some very complicated models sometime
and if there isn't a three shoebox tab
on that spreadsheet like money and money
out money left over I don't even want to
look at it and it's not that hard you
know and I if if you can't figure out if
that third shoebox isn't gonna have
anything in it hey you need to reassess
what what you're doing and iterate and
boy so much of things would be less
complicated so we always get down to the
three shoebox method and we always make
sure that there's something left over in
that third shoebox and if there isn't we
change we change our what we're offering
what we're selling and all that and
after 15 years of doing that the hardest
part is to keep that attitude when
things are going well you know we ripped
apart Alinea after a record year in 2016
raised it to the ground and rebuilt it
because we had maxed out of that
footprint it wasn't going to improve at
all and right now like you said it's not
too late
like I want to pick up on that it is
very much not too late we are at the
beginning of the beginning of some
unknown terrible weird thing that's
happening your listeners may a year from
now listen to this and go god Nick was
so full of he's out of business
it could happen like you know it's like
like my what I live in fear of right now
is hey in September when when all of the
government like you know look we can't
keep printing trillions of dollars
we can't bail out every single business
in America permanently I mean it seems
like we can because we just did but if
we keep doing that you run into things
like hyperinflation and you know at some
point we're gonna probably issue a 50
year bond at 1% and the Chinese
government will probably buy that bond
but at some point that the the ability
of the rest of the world to to want to
consume our debt will will slow down and
so consequently all of us are going to
be left to our own devices sooner rather
than later you know so September so I
reopen my restaurants and we've got
people wearing gloves and we're
practicing social distancing and our
occupancy is 50% of what it used to be
in demand is down 70 or 80 percent and
my revenue has gone and plummeted by 75%
that's what I spent yesterday modeling
out and at some point you just go like
that
it's not really worth being open you
know so at that point I go like well
what would we need to do to make it
worth being open what would we do to be
able to save 95 percent of the jobs and
still make money as this out of business
and rebuild it over the next two or
three years and and I don't have those
answers yet but we're kind of going like
well what do we do
experience-wise what will people want
emotionally then well they'll certainly
want safety in the short term they'll
want a release of some sort I think
humor will be important then but what is
that in terms of a dining experience I
haven't the faintest idea
right so these are the conversations
were having now and I was talking to
grant about it yesterday and trying to
come up with ideas for
or instead of looking at the distancing
as a limitation or the occupancy as a
limitation what kind of weird idea can
we have to make that an asset instead of
liability so I have no idea of what
we're gonna do I don't know if it'll
work or not but that's the part that's
gonna be really hard it's actually not
right now right now the limitations are
so great that all we can do is carry out
like they extended the the stay-at-home
order through May in Illinois yesterday
and I just went oh okay
well for the next four weeks what we
kind of know what we're doing after that
it's a wide open slate and very scary to
be honest people listening who want to
improve and I want to come back to talk
because we didn't really pick up that's
that's my fault
but pick up on the here's a business
that also entirely depends on
restaurants and it's not like you're
only servicing a linnaeus so you can
make up for it right I mean what we're
going to come back to that but for
people listening whether they are in
restaurants or otherwise are there any
particular books or resources that you
have found helpful or would recommend
for improving your thinking and
strategic planning they don't have to
touch on it directly it could be for
instance you like do and I think has a
lot of great leadership lessons it's not
a book about leadership but nonetheless
is is does anything come to mind just
for people who are saying god damn I
wish I studied more economics which I
did not but you might have I wish I
studied derivatives I wish I studied
this I wish I said that but I haven't
how can i hone my thinking do you have
any suggestions they're the same ones
from the last podcast we did I think
there's a list on there and I it's it's
funny you know not some talib on on
Twitter can be very pedantic and kind of
a jerk sometimes but fooled by
randomness
not not the Black Swan as much this
isn't actually a back Black Swan event I
don't think fooled by randomness is over
and over again
a book that I come back to and have
suggested to people to read during this
or to reread because both that and skin
in the game are fascinating and what's
been interesting in this is that you
know he he has the generalized Reuben
principle which is is kind of funny
which is basically like all the airline
CEOs have no skin in the game right so
many of the leaders of our of our big
companies are custodians of those big
companies and they get paid more if the
stock price goes up and so if they take
their capital reserves if they take that
third shoe box and they spend it to get
the stock price going up and they don't
hold you know billions of dollars in
reserve they only do that knowing that
they're gonna get bailed out if
hits the fan like oh wait like oh one
like 89 like now
and so Talib is this is stuff he's been
writing about for 20 years and I have to
say that like you know what people don't
realize is that the airlines you know I
tweeted something like they're too few
to fail like they've they've all merged
together there's not that many of them
and we we certainly will need air travel
in the future and so consequently
everyone's like well yep gotta have to
bail out the airlines but but you really
don't like those planes aren't going
anywhere
and someone will buy those assets and
the airlines will still run and the
employees will still have their jobs so
I I keep coming back to a lot of his his
thinking on that because the people that
I know that are looking for the bailouts
in any industry including hospitality
including software both of which I'm in
are the ones who themselves generally
don't own the things they may look like
they do and they may you may think that
they've got their skin in the game but
they don't they have licensing deals
which is very different the people
who've built their own businesses from
scratch and had bootstrapped them and
whatnot I think you'll find that a lot
of those folks are like my dad and my
dad was a product of the Great
Depression
my dad didn't carry a credit card his
whole life he was like if you can't pay
for it you can't afford it you know and
that's been beaten into me and that like
we did you know after this all happened
like we ran talk in a very capital
efficient manner while some of our
competitors grew at a pace we're growing
300% a year which isn't shabby right
it's it's VC eyebrow-raising worthy
right that said some of our competitors
grew faster by giving their product away
by burning through 60 70 million dollars
and then selling the company for a
couple hundred million those are all the
companies now that are laying off 50
percent of their employees and so
running a fiscally cautious and
intelligent company whether that be your
restaurant or your software company or
your airline or whatnot
you know like biggest example of that's
Apple how many companies is Apple by a
year how much money do they have in the
bank
100 billion plus and there's been times
where people are like Oh Apple should
buy you we're not over a Tesla or Apple
should buy this or apple tree buy that
apples product development cycle as slow
as hell they wait and see what works in
the market and then they just make a
better version of it and you know is
anybody worried about Apple right now
I'm not right so and yet like there are
companies like like my favorite like
Yelp
what did Yelp do well they laid off 50%
of their workforce right away that talib
goes through all of that in great detail
20 years ago and has been right on the
money with a lot of his prescriptive
writings
what are what are some companies that
could be in his hospitality or they
certainly could be outside that you
admire a lot right now or in general
that's tricky certainly they're out
there I think some of the remote
learning I follow again him Austin
Allred on Twitter who has online
programming school and the model of that
I started following him about a year ago
and I think it's got the lambda school
and the the model of that which is so
great is simply like you don't pay for
the school until after you get out and
we get you a career so if we do our job
right we'll take some money you know for
I don't even know what the deal is five
five years after you graduate or
whatever and then if during that time
you become unemployed again you'd stop
paying us right what's fascinating now
is that these universities the great
part of an elite University and I think
you and I both been fortunate to go to
two of them a lot of what we learned I
bet took place outside the classroom
amongst our peer group what's
interesting is that I have a 21 year old
son and he is at a wonderful liberal
arts college and he hasn't been feeling
that he was getting that same experience
that that I got and I honestly thought
it was a failure of of him like you know
or maybe if I was gonna be in a generous
mood I'd blame the school or something
right but I think what happened is that
he associates a lot of his relationships
to be online and virtual you know and so
he stayed in touch like when we when I
went off to college I I couldn't be in
touch everyday with my high school
friends or I couldn't be in touch with
people that I met on the other end of
the world who had similar interests to
me he does and I think if you look at
what Austin's doing with the school is
that he's taking the best most important
parts of the school and realized that
some of the the community aspects can be
done virtually now
I still have I'm not totally sold on
that I'm 52 years old though I bet my
kid agrees with that a hundred percent
like hey I think that I think that he
just thinks you know he's like telling
me get over it old man
so you know you look at companies like
zoom which is really hot now we started
you teasing zoom a year and a half ago
if you had told me five years ago that
like that would be a company that would
grow like that when hey you know what
like Skype video has existed for years
Google Hangouts is free there's all
these free options right why would you
build a video conferencing company well
it's because all those video
conferencing things suck all the ones I
mentioned aren't that great they're free
but they're not they're not
differentiated when we started talk we
started talkin p-ting against opentable
which was completely ubiquitous and I've
had hundreds of people tell me both in
our industry and investors and whatnot
you are completely out of your mind
starting a company competing against
someone who has monopoly and so I the
companies that I like to look at are the
ones that go into a very established
industry and just go hey it's right to
be blown up and done better you know
yeah a lot delivered they like another
people gave that a lot of people gave
that line to Google with respect to
Yahoo yeah and you know I mean like
Google seems impenetrable now right
Facebook seems kind of impenetrable but
yet like tik-tok still came along you
know not something I use but still still
there's there's always room for for a
positive change and you know it's an
interesting question I normally I
probably go on and on about that
question but I'm so in my own weird
space these days because everything's
happening I mean I've we've probably
done for talk in the restaurant group I
bet we've done what two years of work in
eight weeks like you normally what we
accomplished
we in two years we did in eight weeks
well you had to completely I mean I
don't know if completely is the right
modifier just a quick aside
Austin Allred you mentioned at Austin a
UST en and ended his lambda school they
have two schools super interesting you
had to kind of redesign the business if
I'm not mistaken or at least do a hell
of a lot of coding and product upgrading
because as you mentioned opentable are
kind of analog to OpenTable but better
reservations in CRM system for
restaurants and you how long did it take
you to create the to go platform six
days yeah and and and and you know it
was we have a hundred person company and
we service about three thousand
hospitality clients between wineries and
restaurants in 28 countries as I
mentioned we were growing about 300% a
year and as this year started we had
come off a year where we grew by 300%
almost across every metric revenue we
added 40 employees to get to just under
a hundred and we we really were getting
traction for bigger groups and more
casual restaurants and whatnot and then
this happened and just at the same time
where I was saying that I could see that
my restaurants were gonna go to zero
I had this this company with a hundred
employees that were making really
innovative software for the hospitality
industry
and it was gonna go Kevin II was gonna
go completely to zero you know and you
know we have a high high payroll because
we have really highly skilled
individuals and so Canlis restaurant in
Seattle which was a couple weeks ahead
quote-unquote you know of the problem
they were like trying to modify the way
that we handle tables which is unique to
talk to make it into carry out meals and
Brian called up Jeff Kaplan who's the
CEO oh and a really great guy at talk
and and I could really couldn't run the
company without him
and Jeff called me and said you know
we're gonna go to zero and I'm like yeah
yeah I know and he's like I think we
should just do this carryout thing he's
like you're doing it for Alinea you're
already talking about it candless has
already started doing it and the third
party delivery apps charge twenty to
thirty percent like that's we don't need
to do that these people aren't going to
be sending food out the back door this
is gonna be the only option in America
so we got a group together of about
twelve to fifteen design engineering
people and we got on on a video call and
we just said we got to do this in a week
and everyone kind of like you could see
the discomfort because this is the kind
of project that normally we would take
six months to build and we're very
particular about the UX we're very
particular about testing yeah you're
talking about payment processing all
these things and Robyn and Anil who is
our head of engineering who is just an
extraordinary guy he was a machine
learning guy at Google and whatnot he
got off the call and he called me on the
phone and he just said we can do this I
got it there's a couple people who were
like that's not really possible and they
said well you know we're not gonna be
able to test it like it would take weeks
to test and like yeah we're not gonna
test it we're just gonna throw it out
into the world and six days later
candless was using it and we had five
restaurants by day seven we're adding 50
a day now so we went from processing
over a million dollars a day in gross
merchandising value for events and
prepaid reservations and then you know
50s to 60s at 70,000 reservations that
were free besides that to zero and now
we're at a million to a day in four
weeks and we've completely changed the
way that the restaurants can manage the
inventory on the dashboard the backend
side of talk in a way that we're getting
emails every day from restaurants saying
not only is this a lifeline to to the
other side of this crisis but we are
employing people we
like there have been several restaurants
including Alinea by the way which has
had its record revenue day during this
time and so what we were what we managed
to do and what our team managed to do is
is have the urgency of a start-up circa
2002 yeah and we now are working seven
days a week we we hired another person
yesterday our first hire since this all
began to be in our account management
team to help onboard restaurants because
we're adding we're literally working
someone who's working 24 hours a day for
talk right now just onboarding
restaurants and then teaching them how
to do this and then this is the kind of
thing also that expands talk was always
about dynamic and variable pricing for a
time slotted business now what that
means is that your dentist should cost
less on Tuesday than Saturday right
dentists have time slots suddenly
furniture stores have time slots grocery
stores have time slots there are going
to be reasons to gate in a time slotted
way a whole bunch of different kinds of
businesses so now we are talking to all
sorts of businesses that have nothing to
do with the restaurant industry about
time management for reservations and
because we built those data structures
in that way five years ago and we
thought about those time slots almost as
derivatives that's now flexible enough
that we can apply it to say a furniture
store which we just signed yesterday so
again very interesting outcome
unintended of a terrible situation but I
have to say that our team man I we've
never felt more productive more
connected we haven't been in an office
in six weeks I personally don't like
remote work I like to be in an office
but we have been more productive in the
last six seven weeks
than we have in the last year and a half
at an extraordinary pace with really
high quality - that's incredible and you
have a lot of skin in the game just to
bring that back yeah
you know I would like to emphasize that
I've lost 10 pounds I'm stressed out I'm
fourteen hundred emails behind you're
always on the email zero thing right
like I'm not managing all this
well it's chaotic it's not fun I'm
drinking more wine than I should an
evening but you know what like you know
it's like a sense of purpose is what we
all want and I think it's very easy to
have a sense of purpose right now
well Nick this is a this has been yet
another wide-ranging and fascinating
conversation I appreciate you coming
back on people can find talk at explore
toc-toc kake.com
is that right yes please please do
support your local restaurants through
there and they can find you on Twitter
that's probably is that where you're
most active at Nick OCONUS on Twitter
yes Twitter and Instagram and cojones
and Instagram excellent and I will
include links to everything we discussed
in the show notes for everyone
Tim Doug forward slash podcast or just
go to end up blog and search Nick or
Alinea or CONUS and you can find
everything that has been covered is
there anything else you would like to
say or comment on before we wrap up Nick
not at all thank you so much you know
I'm sure that much of what I've said
here is going to be wrong and that's
fine too
and send me some Franklin barbecue next
time you have a beet fairy me angel
coming because of that right now that is
my plan for lunch today as leftovers
can't wait
thanks again Nick always always and to
everybody listening until next time
thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in with your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoyed
this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleep sleep is super important
to me in the last few years I've come to
conclude it is the end-all-be-all that
all good things good mood good
performance good everything seem to stem
from good sleep so I've tried a lot to
optimize it I've tried pills and potions
all sorts of different mattresses you
name it and the last few years I've been
sleeping on a hulex midnight luxe
mattress I also have one in the guest
bedroom and feedback from friends has
always been fantastic it's something
that they comment on helix sleep has a
quiz takes about two minutes to complete
that matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you with helix there's a specific
mattress for each and every body that is
your body also your taste so let's say
you sleep on your side or like a super
soft bed no problem
or if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress that's as firm as a rock
they've got a mattress for you tube
helix was selected as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by GQ
magazine wired Apartment Therapy and
many others just go to helix sleep comm
slash Tim take their two minutes sleep
quiz from they'll match you to a
customized mattress
we'll give you the best sleep of your
life they have a 10-year warranty you
get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up from
you if you don't love it and now my dear
listeners Felix is offering up to $200
off of all mattress orders and 2 free
pillows at helix sleep comm / Tim these
are not cheap pillows either so getting
two for free is an upgraded deal so
that's up to 200 ollars off and two free
pillows at helix sleep comm / Tim that's
helix HP l IX sleep comm / Tim for up to
$200 off so check it out one more time
helix HP l IX sleep comm / tim this
episode is brought to you by shipstation
i've been super impressed with these
guys shipstation is the shipping
software with the most five-star reviews
now speaking as a former ecommerce CEO
back in a previous incarnation when I
was shipping tens of thousands and
hundreds of thousands of products this
is what I wish I had way back in the day
as folks adapt to this changing world
these strange times we are all going to
be buying more stuff online than ever
before and if you're an e-commerce
seller or if you want to be selling more
online if ask yourself are you ready to
meet the demands of our new delivery
economy you can be ready with
shipstation and lots of my friends use
them so why ship station when you're
selling online getting a lot of orders
out fast can be super hard I've
experienced this firsthand how do you
keep track of who gets what which
shipping carrier should you use how do
you process refunds how do you process
returns how do you do all of that are
you getting the best rates shipstation
helps online sellers of any size get
orders out quickly save money on
shipping costs and keep customers happy
they do a few things really really well
you can import more orders from more
places so no matter where you're selling
Amazon Etsy Shopify eBay your own
website wherever ship station brings it
all into one
simple interface making it really easy
to manage from any device including your
cell phone your smartphone you can
instantly rate shop your favorite
carriers and this is a huge deal as a
shipstation user you can get access to
discounted rates that are typically
reserved for much larger companies like
fortune 500 companies that meet certain
minimums just as an example shipstation
just negotiated a new deal with UPS
which rates are discounted as much as 62
percent that has a huge impact on
businesses and on your bottom line your
profit margin and an Amazon Prime world
where people are used to free shipping
small businesses or smaller businesses
can struggle to stay competitive with
high shipping costs shipstation
can help with that you go way beyond
ordinary tracking so there's a
self-serve portal for people who want to
know where their order is when they're
gonna get it etc returns ditto
self-serve it just makes everything
easier that's why shipstation is the
number one choice of online sellers
today you ship more product and less
time with the best rates available and
right now my dear listeners you can try
shipstation free for 60 days when you
use offer code tim t IM there's
absolutely no risk you can start your
free trial without even entering your
credit card info just visit shipstation
dot-com click on the microphone at the
top of the homepage and type in Tim
that's ship station comm then enter
offer code Tim ship station dot-com make
ship happen one more time ship station
comm click on the microphone at the top
and type in Tim that's me see I am check
it out
you